aber damals luca meine lieben freunde
ihr seht schon ich habe mich ein
bisschen schick gemacht hat mir ein
weißes hemd aus dem kleiderschrank
geholt denn ich habe ja viel arbeiten
das ist hart
hallo ich bin hammam
[Musik]
gesagt hätte
natürlich auch mit dabei
die hat sich auch etwas schicken
macht findet eben eine platte aus sogar
wie ich gehört nur mir
dem sollte auch sonst gern mein freund
brauchst du jetzt schon ja
man hat übrigens ab heute knapp zwei
wochen drei wochen bei der wohnung auch
beziehungsweise selber laufen ist auf
jeden fall neuerdings unserer
assistentin und hat sich direkt wohnten
video überlegt wo von sommer und ich
noch gar keine ahnung haben also was
geht
ich war ein bisschen einkaufen für euch
ja ich kann nun die kamera nicht so
lange suchen ich war ein bisschen
einkaufen für euch in einem bekannten
ein euro shop und das xoom ihr könnt
euch mal die schönen sachen anschauen
und vielleicht auch zukünftig verwenden
da gibt die tüte ja
und ich
dachte schon
du kannst bewege mich keinen strom
die größten anfangen
das ist einfach eine monopoly junior
spielmacher in xl
bekanntlich luca rollt jetzt war ich
dann immer abziehen beim monopoly dies
das anders ich bin jetzt 40 gramm sowie
[Musik]
die toilette geht dann wusste man
einfach
das gab es in den eindruck in kraft trat
[Musik]
mir wird das hier passen tierpark weil
sortieren und ein
ganzer war man
[Musik]
bisher die büchereien weil du denkst
dass es langweilig bis
zu irgendwann mal die tour fällt das tut
ein
bisschen rein stecken könnte die
regierung wenn du bist du täglich
machen weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
sagen reist als nächstes in die tüte
rein und holt
viel gewinnt was ist das kennst du nicht
gewinnen sondern darf sich auch mal wie
eine vier gewinnt
[Musik]
im nächsten mit produkt was unsere
assistentin geholt hat ein
zusammenhang
verwies nächsten produkt vielleicht mal
ganz tief rein in die wundertüte der
crystal cruises reinpacken hat ford das
protein shake könnte schließen dem auto
gelaufen dass die muskeln bekommt aber
eigentlich stört euch das mal an dass
sie alex hat euch das hier mal an dann
ist was
du denkst an diesem film ist so ein
alpaka bringt mich da die malstifte
passabel da malia bubble bobble also
machen wir mit dem nächsten boxer eine
liebe freunde
ich
bin 22 jahre alt aber das ist alles
spielzeug was hier noch gebrauchen
könnte
was
denkst du ist
haben wir sandra hauptnahrungsquelle
einen tag später
fünfjährige hätten das schon das
zusammengebaut zwei tage später
sei froh
dass mit dusch habe
ich gesagt dass man habe gerry weber
und so
ist das loch wird die schraube
warum sich zu machen ja darf das
verhalten
glückskeks anti stress mache ich also
hast du dich nun können und anti stress
stets
etwas sagt was denkt ihr steht da drin
jeder dafür einen satz sagen was er
denkt da verbinden kommentiert knicks
haben
jolo einsatz
gefordert ich glaube da steht drinnen
genieße die die sonne des tages wie du
den abend genießen was denkst du wenn du
auf deine innere seele hörst fällt die
last von mir ab
jolo kraft
qualität wenn du mit ihm
getroffen
[Musik]
tommy nun zum ja nicht mal setzten
produkte noch einiges drin ist wir haben
hey du denkst wir sind hauptberuflich
mal alle das mit dem rufzeichen stimmen
sondern sehr ehrlich ist der coole das
kann ich jetzt schon sagen was sie
machen will
[Musik]
ich mal jetzt nicht mehr
haben gesehen was
ich höre ich mal ich an sich das popkomm
eine trockenmauer schreibt man die
kommentare im zuge kommen oder dass ich
das pop waren schon gar nicht wieder
kommentare camille du willst dass sich
ein spannender machen
salzig
[Musik]
okay nicht weiter machen willst
so
lässt sich später
selbst die zeit für dich teil mit
zahnstocher
umfasst das in
einem bonbon will schütte
luca das war hatte meinem mund mit
wasser brot gemacht gerade an einer
stelle würde ich das heutige video auch
beenden meine lieben freunde denn euch
diese erste glorreich kreative idee von
h-milch um einen kanal gefallen hat das
ist ein daumen hoch unter abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
weitere videos nicht verpassen wollte
sandra hat ist nicht in der beschreibung
verlinkt
ich hätte lieber kommen läuft dann
wirklich
verlinkten geschrieben wird